now Mitch is fine still mad at me though
you know how touchy he can be did he
remember when we tried to cheer him up
after his first ice skating
competition how were we supposed to know
third place is a good thing remember he
tromped off across that muddy field in
his skates he sunk like a woolly mammoth
hey Dei if you're around the 4th of July
you should come by and watch the wedding
video oh no we're out of town in
August oh all right well soon okay oh
Dei I don't think I have your
new okay it's magic time everyone Phil
please take your place beneath our
Majestic Arch cue the cortet where's the
other one he rode with a gater who flip
this truck why do good things happen to
everyone but me let's send the flower
girl before she's a flower teen
teenager so sad
sorry what is yeah like I'm the problem
is your dad here yeah you should be
right oh oh my God he's out on the
sidewalk on the phone do you want me to
go get him no no I don't let's just come
on let's just do
this
mitel is this really how you want to get
married well it's not ideal now you
people don't have any R to throw because
they're chewing a rod of starvation half
of our guests are on the lawn and there
go the sprinklers okay let's just call
time of death on this all right hey
everybody um thank you so much for uh
for dealing with all this today it means
a lot to us but unfortunately this is
not going you can't do this yeah I'm way
ahead of you Dad and thank you for
stopping by what I mean is you can't get
married like this you two deserve the
kind of wedding you've been talking
about non-stop for the last nine months
what do you mean you bring it up every
chance that you I know what non-stop
means trust me okay
now what are we all standing around for
my son's getting married today all right
it's what this golf club needs shake it
up a little go on dear how often do your
fathers get married so far one two why
am I still seeing
you take your seat D we're about to
start actually I thought you and I would
take a little
[Music]
walk I remember it like it was yesterday
the day that Mitchell came home from the
hospital in a very unfashionable white
diaper with three strands of scraggly
Raggedy Andy hair if he's doing it I'm
doing it you come and Barb you old Sweet
Talker wait for
me we were
inseparable I was his big sister his big
brother his Nemesis his protector his
best friend
friend I was his first
partner and I loved every minute of it
thank you all for being here on this
happy
occasion they say the best marriages
contain just a little bit of
magic believe me I
[Music]
know we're gathered here today to join
two amazing people so naturally I was a
little picky when it came to who was
going to be replacing me and then I met
this Cam and sure he was warm and funny
and
[Music]
loving Cameron do you take Mitchell to
be your husband I do Cameron would you
please place this ring on Mitchell's
finger Mitchell do you take Cameron to
be your
husband I
do then by the powers vested in Me by
the state of California I am privileged
to pronounce you spouses for life you
may now kiss your
husband I wondered was he really
everything I wanted for my
brother was he really the best person no
I'm the best
person and now I am very pleased to
raise the glass and introduce for the
first time ever on our fourth try great
husbands Mitch and
[Applause]
[Music]
cam